la población de una ciudad crece a una
tasa de rd de 300 por el elevado al 0.3
porter personas por año donde este es el
tiempo en años en el tiempo de igual a
dos años la población de la ciudad es de
1200 personas cuál será su población
entre igual a 7 y acá abajo nos
preguntan cuál es la expresión que nos
ayuda a resolver el problema primero hay
que tener cuidado no nos piden que
resolvamos la pregunta del problema lo
que nos piden es que nos basemos en ella
y viene el problema para resolver la
pregunta cuál es la expresión que nos
ayuda a resolver el problema usando
algunos símbolos de cálculo así que qué
tal si pausas el vídeo e intentas
encontrar la solución
bien intentemos recordar lo que nos dan
nos dan una función de tasa de cambio
por lo que si quieres encontrar el
cambio en la población de un tiempo a
otro lo que necesitamos es encontrar la
integral definida de la función de la
tasa de cambio que en este caso es r dt
ok
dt desde un cierto tiempo hasta otro en
este caso va a ser desde el tiempo
inicial que es el tiempo de t igual a
dos años hasta el tiempo final que en
este caso es de t igual a siete años la
integral de la función de la tasa de
cambio de tema y lo que nos dice esta
expresión es cómo cambia la población
desde el año igualados hasta el año
igual a 7 así que mejor lo voy a notar
esto de aquí lo que nos dice es el
cambio en la población ahora en cuidado
no nos preguntan cuál es el cambio en la
población nos piden la población
igual a 7 por lo tanto necesitamos saber
cuál es la población en este caso entre
igual a 2 años ok ya esto sumarle el
cambio en la población desde te iguala
dos años hasta te iguala siete años pero
por suerte sabemos que entre igual a dos
años nuestra población era de 1.200
personas por lo tanto si quieres saber
la población entre igual a 7 debes de
tomar la suma de 1.200 personas
más el cambio en la población desde te
igualados hasta te igual a 7 que como ya
sabemos es la integral definida de la
función de la tasa de cambio
dt que en este caso la tasa de cambio es
esta función que tengo aquí a la que
incrementa la población así que podemos
ver que claramente es el inciso de muy
bien y podemos ver rápidamente las otras
opciones el inciso b es simplemente el
cambio en la población desde t igualados
hasta de igual a 7 y como podemos ver es
una función creciente aquí lo puedes ver
entonces esta integral nos dice cuánto
crece en la población desde t igualados
la strata igual a 7 pero no no es lo que
queremos ok el inciso se nos dice como
incrementa la población desde t igual a
0 hasta que igual a 7 y seguramente me
dirás oye porque esta no es la población
que buscamos
bueno sería la opción correcta si no
existiera población entre igual a 0 pero
no podemos suponer eso
tal vez la ciudad se estableció en un
principio con 10 personas o con 1000
personas aún no sé por lo que sean así
que en definitiva esta tampoco es mi
opción correcta la opción a por su parte
toma la derivada ok es un poco difícil
poder imaginar qué representa esta
derivada esto sería como la tasa de
cambio de la tasa de cambio entre igual
a 7 - la tasa de cambio de la tasa de
cambio entre igualados por lo cual
tampoco es lo que buscamos y en
definitiva voy a cancelar la ok entonces
mi opción correcta es el inciso de m
y qué te parece si hacemos otro
ejercicio como este para eso voy a
quitar este ejercicio
y voy a traer este de aquí dice la
profundidad de un tanque de agua cambia
con una tasa de cambio de rd igual a 0.3
por tm centímetros por minuto donde t es
el tiempo en minutos en el tiempo de
igual a cero la profundidad del tanque
es de 35 centímetros cuál es el cambio
en la profundidad del tanque durante el
cuarto minuto cual es la expresión que
nos ayuda a resolver el problema bien
pausa el vídeo e intenta de nuevo
encontrar la expresión que buscamos es
decir la expresión que nos dará el
cambio en la profundidad del tanque
durante el cuarto minuto bien ya hemos
hablado sobre cómo encontrar el cambio
en una función para ello tomamos la
integral definida de la función de la
tasa de cambio sobre el tiempo adecuado
observan nos piden este cambio durante
el cuarto minuto
y eso es lo importante hay que saber
cuál es el cuarto minuto para así poder
encontrar los límites de nuestra
integral definida porque en definitiva
vamos a tomar la integral de la función
r dt m dt de hecho puedes ver que todas
las opciones tienen la integral de r de
tdt pero la parte más interesante es
interpretar esta idea del cuarto minuto
es justo lo que queremos saber cuáles
van a ser nuestros límites de
integración así que para ello qué te
parece si dibujamos por aquí un par de
ejes voy a suponer que este es mi eje de
james este es mi eje del tiempo deja de
ponerle nombre este va a ser mi eje
de bien igual a rt
mientras que este va a ser mi eje del
tiempo y bueno el primer minuto va a ir
desde el tiempo de igual a 0 hasta el
tiempo igual a 1 el segundo minuto va a
ir desde el tiempo de igual a 1 hasta el
tiempo de igualados el tercer minuto va
a ir desde el tiempo de igualados hasta
el tiempo de igual a 3 y el cuarto
minuto va a ir desde el tiempo de igual
a 3 hasta el tiempo de igual a 4 si
observas esta es una función que nos da
una recta es una función lineal que se
ve más o menos así ahora cuál es el
cuarto minuto bueno observa este de aquí
es mi primer minuto
este es mi segundo minuto mi tercer
minuto y mi cuarto minuto por lo tanto
lo que estoy buscando es el área bajo la
función de la tasa de cambio entre estos
dos tiempos es decir esta área que estoy
pintando
en este momento y ahora ya sabemos
cuáles son mis límites de integración
vamos a tomar esta integral definida
desde igual a 3 hasta t igual a 4 así
que vamos a buscar la expresión que nos
den el área que estoy pintando y bueno
se observa es justo lo que nos dicen el
inciso a de lujo ten cuidado puedes
estar tentado a seleccionar la opción b
tal vez puedas pensar que el cuarto
minuto es pasándote igual a 4 pero como
acabamos de ver este sería el quinto
minuto entonces esta opción no es la
correcta y voy a cancelar la el inciso
se nos muestra el cambio durante los
primeros cuatro minutos y no es durante
el cuarto minuto así que también voy a
cancelar la y el inciso tm bueno es una
integral que que me da 0 esta integral
que representa el cambio en la función
desde t igual a 3 hasta t igual a 3
en un solo instante por lo tanto no hay
tiempo alguno de 3 a 3 y entonces voy a
cancelar esta opción ahora si podemos
decir que la respuesta es el inciso am y
hemos terminado nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo